from the Sacramento King in the konjac
Buddy hield what a job he has done this
year very competitive but he got a
stroke he got an effortless girlfriend
he got an after the stroke man he comes
in having made the third most
three-point field goals this season yet
in the NBA 207 of them I got making 22
in its round your target number is 22
for him 22 well that means you've got to
make a cup and you got to make these in
cash you needed that
it's interesting how he's going always
on his right side to collect the balls
as opposed to just net generally is best
painter's baby make this right here
now we've got to be perfect down here so
he's always going to the right side over
here there we go I gotta find it he's
starting to find it he thinks he got 17
do time here tray young take your time
1923
what
[Applause]
he got he has the women and what a
naughty he made his last six
wow what a Wow and most of the guys are
electing to have their money right as
their last rocket it paid off right here
for buddy here oldie way and here's the
thing about Devin Booker and Buddy is
they don't not leave they do not use
their legs yeah it's all arms they're
not like a book book - it's like I did
something about beer what'd he tell her
he's good he can shoot again right now
basketball Mississippi or now here is
the Bahamian buddy hield on a Kanaka
two-time Big twelve buddy
college basketball player of the year at
OU you remember he started slow in that
first round and really picked it up
buddy-buddies
big picnic Kobe Bryant fans Kobe would
have seen him play in college I
guarantee he went as he dedicates this
to Kobe
he said NBA record for the most
three-point shots made by a player in
the first three years of this this is
his signature he shootin like come on
this is going down he needs this right
here though he needs this because he
still has his money rap he got a free
book of winter his money back he had 20
when he went to his money left
[Applause]
you need this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
shot shot he made seven of its run stage
my buddy
Bernie I like that he's not even jumping
at all on me this tiptoe he made eight
money balls spectacular Wow exactly
that's the three point position on the
get bike looking but he can't believe it
love it body heal is your champion in
Chicago ladies and gentlemen please
welcome president self division at
PepsiCo beverages North America Derrick
Lewis who's here to present the 2020
Mountain Dew three-point contest trophy
to Buddy hield
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen once again Kristen
Ledlow a one-point win over a previous
winner I'd imagine
makes this trophy just a little bit
sweeter huh
first of all I want to thank God forgive
me the opportunity come on in before
them and Chicago in this all-star
weekend that's all I got to say a man of
few words but you told me you had what
it takes to win it and you certainly did
give it up one more time for your
Mountain Dew three-point contest
champion buddy hield that's awesome man
that is awesome of what man the skills
and this 3-point competition has been
unbelievable tonight we've had one
three-point contest winner from the
kings pays your stay on him get the
shade on okay you know two and I'll sit
now put the name Buddy hield right there
from Chicago you're watching the 20/20
State Farm all-star